hello everyone this is the last video
I'm making from the match alpha zero
versus stockfish and please don't ask me
to do any more videos if we continue
doing this we'll be unable to enjoy
human chess for the rest of our lives or
until young Misha starts playing at a
3,000 elo rating but you know who knows
when that might happen
so this is another game where alpha has
the white pieces and it's it's a
brilliant example how to sacrifice your
pawns I mean alpha sacrifices upon and
the crippled stockfish for the rest of
the game you'll see what I mean by this
again we have d4 Knight to f6 c4 e6
Knight to f3 and Bishop and b6 the
queen's indian defense g3 Bishop to b7
Bishop to g2 now Bishop to b4 check
Bishop d2 blocking Bishop back to e7 9th
to c3 c 6 now II for D v e5 Knight to e4
and alpha castles and here we have
Bishop to a6 attacking this pawn twice
and the pawn can capture on d5 because
the rook on f1 is hanging and here a
very interesting move by alpha 0 b3 it
sacrifices a pawn and the stop fish has
the option of either capturing the night
and then grabbing a pawn or winning the
bishop prepare with knife capture Sundy
to stock fish decides to go for Knight
captures on c3 Bishop captures on c3 and
now we have deep captures on c4 grabbing
a pawn and this is alphas idea B for now
and for the price of one pawn this
Bishop on a6 is looking very silly now
and although I do think this is a very
nice variation to remember that alpha
just played I don't think we'll be
seeing any Queen's Indian defenses for
black in any talk Grandmaster games I
mean if they see alpha zeros games
against the Queen's Indian defense then
it's very likely they're not gonna play
it b5 and night to d2 and now alpha zero
has a very important mission for this
night it's coming to e4 and then to c5
and from c5 it will block this C
spawn from ever being pushed to c5 and
then this bishop will be locked in for
the rest of the game
we'd have castles Knight to e4
but the b7 and now first Queen to g4
stopping any ideas of c5 if you push c5
now you lose the game immediately as
black wouldn't really mind giving up
upon to release this bishop but Knight
to f6 and black is lost for example
Bishop captures he captures on f6 you're
threatening checkmate
and also the bishop on b7 after black
stops this Queen captures and f6 simply
Bishop captures b7 you lose a piece and
the rock on a8 is coming off next
so after g4 Knight the d7 was played and
now Knight to c5 attacking the bishop
but alpha zero isn't really interested
in grabbing this Bishop it's it's a
useless piece it's just that the c5 is a
very nice outpost for the night so
stockfish eliminates at night factors on
c5 d captures on c5 and now as the c6
bone and the b5 phone are locked in here
on light squares this Bishop can no
longer enter the game by any means a
five by stockfish a3 now a capture
somebody for AP after some before and
stuff stock fish exchanges a pair of
rocks here and Queen to d3 it seems like
it managed to infiltrate alpha 0 Rose
position but after row 2 c1 and rook to
a8 now may be threatening ideas like
rook to a 2 it does seem like an
interesting idea alpha 0 simply plays h4
and Queen back to d8 by stockfish if you
try something like rope to a 2 to
infiltrate the position then Bishop to
e4 attacking the Queen now h5 trying to
deflect the Queen from the defense of
the bishop on e4 but after Queen f4 and
Queen to d7
rook to Queen to f3 first attacking the
h5 pawn and after black defense this g6
then rook to d1 would attempt on the
Queen and whites white position is
it's really good here this is a this is
excellent for white so instead after h4
Queen to d8 was played by stockfish
Bishop to e4 now Queen to c8 and King to
g2 Queen to c7 we have Queen - Queen to
h5 attacking the h7 pawned g6 now
between back to g4 Bishop to f8 h v now
rock to d8 Queen to h4 Queen to e7
offering a trade of Queens now Queen to
f6 and stock fish stock fish doesn't
want to exchange wings here
it plays Queen to e8 if you play Queen
captures on f6 here after it captures on
f6 it's a it's going straight into the
endgame and still black can't get rid of
I mean this bishop on b7 is not playing
the game so it's like blacks being down
a piece it can't afford exchanging
Queens
so after Queen to f6 Queen to d8 rock -
h1 now rook to d7 h capture son g 6f
captures on g6 and now Queen to h4 we
have Queen to e7 again offering a trade
of Queens Queen to g4 rock to d8 and
Bishop to b2 Queen to f7 now Bishop to
c1 and now c3 and it's probably the seat
remove was played to do a limit the
movement of this Bishop but the starfish
will actually lose this pawn now Bishop
to e3 Bishop to e7 and now Queen 3 - the
queen is now coming for this pawn bishop
to f8 Queen c2 and Bishop to g7 Queen
captures on c3 and Queen to d7 rook to
see one Queen to c7 now with a double
attack on the e5 pawn but Bishop to g5
first would a tempo on the rook rook to
f8 + f4 now we have h6 Bishop to f6
Bishop captures on f6 each captures on
f6 and Queen to f7
and now it seems like stockfish is ready
to grab this pawn but this this doesn't
this isn't as good for black that stuff
which would hope you it is rock to
anyone now and it's it's just the worst
position for black Queen captures and f6
was played Queen captures rook captures
and now rook to a7
now the rook is going after this silly
Bishop and b7 and the problem is only
way to defend it is rook to f7 I mean
you can go Bishop to c8 but then you get
rook e8 and you immediately lose the c6
pawn store up to f7 and now Bishop
captures and g6 grabbing back that extra
pawn and now white is simply much better
rook to d7 King to f2 came to f8 now g4
Bishop to c8 and now stock fish would
definitely like to exchange rooks and
then maybe maybe this game could be
played you know this Bishop could go to
d7 EA to me exchange bishops and play on
but still you have to see that alpha has
to point islands and stock fish has
three point islands so you know this is
basic chess to pond islands are better
than three pounds
so rook to e8 pinning the bishop
rook to c7 now you have to defend the
bishop and also kind of defend the c6
pawn if you play something like King to
g7 you know if white captures this
Bishop then starfish captures this one
this isn't good rock character scheme
characters and then King - III not
immediately capturing the c6 bone but
first came to e3 and not allowing the
rook to infiltrate with rook to d4 and
attacking both of these pawns
so after King III it's pretty much over
now King f6 now rook captures rook who
goes for the other pawn and after a
couple of checks there are no more
checks and after work moves you capture
the other pond and out with being up two
points a completely winning position so
after rook to a8 rook the c7 was played
and I came to e3 improving the position
of the king
h5 and it seems like like a weird move
almost as if stockfish blundered in time
trouble but you you can to protect this
point this point is is gonna be lost
either way if something like King to e7
then King e4 and after something like
Bishop to d7 I mean you have to play
something you have to maybe somehow
activate the bishop then Rock h8 you're
losing that pawn either way
so after King III h5g captures on h5 now
alpha is up upon King g7 rook to a2 now
rookie 7 Bishop to g4 now attacking the
c6 pawn d5 now Bishop captures pawn
captures with check King captures now
alpha is up two points rook f7 check
King e5 and this is now only a matter of
small technique Raja to check King f6
now King is coming for the b5 point
Bishop f5 king b6 a rock to h4 King to
a5 now first protecting the pawn Bishop
to g4 now Bishop captures king e7 and
after rule g3 Bishop c8 rook III check
King f7 and Bishop to e2 in this
position stockfish resigned so as you
can see after that one point sacrifice
and that night c5 move that allowed
these pawns to control the b5 and c6
pawn this Bishop was locked in for the
rest of the game and although it did get
untangled in the end of the game it was
it was too late for him black had to
give up too many points to activate this
Bishop and I mean it's a it's a really
good example of how to play chess you
know just you know that Bishop a6 I mean
I don't know if it's a good move
obviously not
I mean maybe you need to play it somehow
differently but after that before it
really it really just ruined the blacks
blacks whole game that Bishop was locked
in for the rest of the game so yeah this
is a 5th game I'm showing by
alpha zero versus stockfish I do hope
you enjoyed them and all the rest of
them as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here but I will put a
link in the description where you can
check it play check out the playlist
with all of the five videos think all
for watching and don't ask for more
alpha versus stockfish videos I will see
you soon